she called her karen yeah even all white
dudes she's like yo shut up karen yeah
and he's old this dude just discovered
that word yesterday he's on the flight
shut up karen hey shout out to the old
man
welcome to the club
[Laughter]
talking [ __ ] to a [ __ ]
shut up y'all [ __ ] like [ __ ] but why
did you put your mask up
look at this stupid way why did he put
his mask up like it's turned into a
schoolyard fight no no he should do it
it's like this
cup i thought you were afraid of cold i
thought you were afraid of cozy what
happened but you out here arguing with
somebody about not if you had your mask
up you could protect yourself
oh i
i hope he hold he goes veteran on it
right no no this this wiley's out of
pocket shout out you're fighting with
the old man what's wrong with you i
wouldn't [ __ ] you up
[Music]
[Music]
get back
hypothetical but if you're not trying to
catch covert and somebody's on mass
maybe what you don't do is get up in the
face and start screaming while both your
mouths are open just make out with the
old man if you want to cover that badly
i don't know what's wrong with you at
this point i don't know if you gotta
think for old names but like why are you
opening this dude's face put your mask
on
put your mask on
put your mask on
now you got it
put your mask on scoop it put your mask
on
put your mask on
put your mask on here
put your mask on
put your mask on
put your mask on
that's what it feels like
yo hold up you know what i'm mark please
i'm gonna need you to make a song with
me right now okay
yes sir put your mask on
put your mask on
put your mask on gang gang put your mask
i don't promise you
we'll have a remix of this in no time
and [ __ ] we're going to feature your
karen ass well boy we need to give uh
marquis uh some some love well no no not
some love but we need to give him like
hold on we got the put your mask on
put your mask on put your mask on
put your mask on put your jump mask on
work with that
you have to give them some variation and
[ __ ] i'm not mad at you but monkey's
he's mark you look like he's such a
genius we don't need to do that
the land of the free
e
free
yeah
that's what i do and if you don't know
about it we're about to put you on
manzoji's
[Music]
um
what happened what was the was the
trigger of that was a trigger though
what happened why did you get up and
start talking to a random white man all
right let's find out like what happened
delta karen is revealed to be a former
playboy model baywatch actress and
raiders cheerleader who now works as a
realtor fbi arrest what is it with every
like [ __ ] x-porn star
an
x-like cheerleader like whatever working
as a realtor
i'm not crazy right they all started
selling houses he's like you want to
tour this house would you like to check
the master bedroom
we have a very special gift for you
they do you like cats they really do
well this bedroom comes the tour of a
pussycat okay anyways they really do
they knew i was looking to notice i was
like
[ __ ] you was hoeing there
yeah but now i'm selling you a home i'm
hoeing now it's at home yeah you went
from a house record to a home building
digress let's get one the older male
passenger had been eating at the time he
was approached by an unmasked cornwall
and told to mask up the pair shattered
exploded he was eating
shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] if you don't get
the [ __ ] up this man okay we made fun
but this this what this white man was a
hundred percent right i was about to say
a hundred percent white when he called
you a karen he was both of those things
he was muslim yeah
i hope you see this video brother yes he
he was eating leave the man leave the
man alone yes just leave me alone
anyways man [ __ ] that no no did she get
the did the police take her
she was arrested
yeah good now we got
what would you like to say
shut up
man what's eating you're supposed to
take your mask off when you eat that's
just dumb appreciate her
that's that's just stupid agreed my god
what is your problem i don't know what
it is that people like like they need to
i'm a giant [ __ ] like
[Music]
listen i think some people aren't happy
and i think the
unmasked unvexed population seems to be
the heart of all their problems that's
what they like pretend right they're sad
it's them they're depressed it's them
their business is failing it's them
right so some of these people see them
and they lose all rationality i've just
seen people go crazy and to be fair i
think a certain level it comes from our
government because they've instilled so
much fear in the population right that
irrational responses have become pretty
standard these what we're talking about
right now in attract interactions like
this they've had like 5 000 of them over
the course of the last year on flights
so
there's a lot of craziness in regards to
these rules and how people are very
afraid now maybe that's part of it or
maybe
the [ __ ] is just crazy [ __ ] just be
crazy some of them are just crazy it's
not just ladies even some dudes them
[ __ ] be crazy too ambitious yes so
to me i don't know what's happening but
she's clearly wrong she's going to jail
now shout out to him i was going to have
charges yeah
yeah shout out to him he handled it oh
you're going to jail yeah good for him
because that girl was annoying the hell
out of it and you was not even in the
flight no it's like mind your [ __ ]
business put your mask on
people have really like lost their minds
with that [ __ ]
i remember one time i got to the
restaurant door
okay the waiter's there he's like how
many people two is that cool so i got my
mask on as i'm walking to the table i'm
starting to remove my mask and somebody
says keep it on
what
i'm about to keep it on
we walk like five more steps to sit down
i thought i had my mask off the whole
time and then the girl with i was with
she took off her mask and the girl was
looking at me the other person the one
who said something they were like give
me a weird look
does it matter four or five steps are
here like what are you smoking but
people are crazy with these rules now
yeah crazy yeah yeah yeah somebody said
this i don't know who said this they're
like somebody was doing like a pro
mask and mandate rap song
and i'm like yo rap
these rap [ __ ] they're making rap lame
since one was like rap pro government
you feel me
you ever thought you'd see like a day
where nwa is like yo we pro mandates
bruh
[ __ ] the police but we
but we down for these mandates could you
ever imagine a time [ __ ] the police but
we're like we're down for the
the mass policing
shutdown that's my point that's my point
it's like it's like people have lost
their minds to fear and irrationality
they just doing things that make no
sense they're making the most y'all
making the most
stop making the most
so yeah i don't think too much more to
that story
you know karen's going to be karen's
adam
this is the mask edition this is karen's
karen's gone wild mask edition that's
pretty much we need a dvd
somebody to sell a dvd for just kids
gone wild we don't nobody has dvds no
more i'd buy one for this
i only have a dvd player and i buy a dvd
player just for that
so business idea for anybody's watching
anything